nous allons reprendre
les travaux de la mission parlementaire
sur l'évaluation de la loi classe
Leonetti avec une audition importante
celle du Comité consultatif national
d'éthique je vais tout d'abord présenté
les excuses du corps à porter Didier
Martin qui nous rejoindra en cours
d'audition mais qui est bloqué dans son
train je suis très heureux de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui
pour pour cette audition je salue
évidemment la je souhaitais la bienvenue
à l'inclès régisse Aubry et Annabelle
degré du loup
d'avoir merci d'avoir bien voulu
accepter cette cette invitation
bon formellement je vais vous présenter
à l'inclès mais c'est nécessaire dans
cette maison tout particulièrement vous
êtes connus et reconnu pour la qualité
de l'expertise et des travaux que que
vous avez mené pendant 20 ans en tant
que député de la Vienne que ce soit sur
l'enseignement supérieur sur la santé et
bien évidemment sur les questions de de
bioéthique et de fin de vie vous avez
été aussi maire de Poitiers président de
l'agglomération du Grand Poitiers et
vous avez été nommé donc en 2021 au
Comité consultatif national d'éthique
pour les sciences de la vie et de santé
puisque c'est la terminologie
exacte de cette belle organisme et vous
êtes bien évidemment le co-auteur et le
corps rapporteur de la loi dite
cleisonetti que nous avons pour mission
ici d'évaluer ce qui fait de votre
audition évidemment un moment attendu un
moment important et sans nul doute
éclairant pour notre travail
j'accueille aussi avec plaisir régisse
Aubry vous êtes évidemment bien connu de
tous ceux qui savent aux questions de la
fin de vie vous êtes un spécialiste des
soins palliatifs vous êtes chef du pôle
autonomie handicap qui regroupe les
services de neurologie de jerry-artrie
de douleur et soins palliatifs au CHRU
de Besançon vous êtes chercheur associé
à l'Institut national des études
démographiques et professeur associé des
universités vous avez été coordinateurs
du Programme national de développement
des soins palliatifs entre 2008 et 2012
et président de l'Observatoire national
de la fin de vie évidemment membre du
CCNE
et j'accueille aussi madame Annabelle
dégrée du Loup vous êtes madame
démographe directrice de recherche pour
le développement l'IRD et vos recherches
ont porté sur les enjeux populationsnels
et sociaux des maladies
particulièrement les maladies
infectieuses en Afrique affectueuses en
Afrique et chez les immigrés en France
et vous êtes donc également membre du
CCNE alors nous souhaitons évidemment
vous interroger tout particulièrement
suite à la vie du CCNE la vie 139
intitulée question éthique relatives aux
situations de fin de vie autonomie et
solidarité un avis qui a été voté en
comité plénier du 30 juin 2022
alors certains membres du CCN ont
souhaité apporter une contribution de
type réserves qui a été finalisée le 8
septembre 2022 nous y reviendrons et cet
avis a été rendu public le 13 septembre
2022 alors dans un premier temps je vais
donner la parole aux deux corps à
porteurs à l'inclès et Régis Aubry
puisque vous avez porté la vie votée
donc en juin 2022 pour que vous puissiez
nous présenter
le cet avis les différents éléments que
vous avez souhaité porter à la
connaissance des citoyens et puis dans
un deuxième temps nous nous reviendrons
sur un certain nombre de questions sur
les réserves qui ont été émises et sur
l'application concrète de la loi dont
vous êtes le co-auteur monsieur classe
donc je vous donne la parole
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs
je suis heureux on trouvait ici dans une
situation indifférente
mais je crois que six ans après il est
nécessaire
d'évaluer la loi que le Parlement
avait voté en 2016 et auquel Jean
Léonetti moi-même avons contribué
c'est une des raisons qui ont fait que
le CCNE c'est auto saisie j'insiste
c'est auto saisie
suite à une nette de mission de
Jean-François delfresci et de
rapporteurs trois rapports initialement
avec des idées mais une importateur a vu
son mandat terminé en cours
d'élaboration de cet avis ce qu'il fait
que aujourd'hui de rapporteurs régissent
et moi-même rendre compte de cet avis
on va se répartir la tâche avec Régis
peut-être
un mot sur la loi 2016
je pourrais vous dire qu'elle est
parfaite il y a rien à voir je crois que
cette loi 2016 vous la connaissez par
cœur
je ferai
trois remarques la première remarque
c'est que la loi 2016 reposait avant
tout et en toile de fond sur le
développement des soins palliatifs
6 ans après et Régis il reviendra
il y a encore sur ce sujet un énorme
travail à faire
ce n'est pas uniquement un problème
financier
c'est que ces soins palliatifs
que j'appelle soin de la personne ou
en médecine de la personne
ne sont pas suffisamment pris en compte
dans la formation initiale
dans la formation continue
peu de laboratoire de recherche sont
inscrits à l'inseme
et si on regarde les programmes de
recherche sur la NR pas de programme pas
d'appel à projet sur ce sujet
pratiquement pas de PUPH
donc c'est un sujet qui nous interpelle
tous bien sûr le législateur et
l'exécutif mais ça interpelle aussi
les structures représentatives de nos
universités
des facultés de médecine et des projets
d'établissement du CH
mais je pense que c'est un préalable à
tout
20 départements aujourd'hui se trouve
sans unité de son palliatif je ne parle
pas
de
des EHPAD ou à domicile
deuxième remarque que je fais sur la loi
elle n'a pas été évaluée on a
cette loi c'est trois nouveaux droits et
je viens juste
c'est la quatrième loi en 20 ans
où chacune de ces lois
ont la réglé l'attention entre
solidarité et autonomie 99 et soins
palliatifs une loi de solidarité
2002 Kushner
loi sur la possibilité à un patient
d'interrompre de demander l'interruption
de ces traitements ou à d'autonomie
2005 la loi sur l'optimisation
déraisonnable et 2016 trois nouveaux
droits directives anticipées
qui sont contraignantes
personne de confiance et la station
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès
lorsque le pronostic vital est engagé à
court terme avec la rythme tout
traitement
directive anticipée
deux sujets
rédigent directement
pas de sens de directives anticipées
et vous savez je connais une vie un peu
mieux que les autres Poitiers
le CHU avec l'aide de l'ARS et je crois
que c'est une première en France a
décidé de recruter une infirmière
qui a fait un parcours en cancérologique
qui a fait un parcours en soins
palliatifs et qui a fait un parcours en
EHPAD tout simplement pour vulgariser
développer la connaissance des
directives anticipées
cette notion directive anticipée donc
pas suffisamment développé et aussi
chose importante et monsieur le
Président vous avez suivi des le débat à
l'époque nous on souhaitait avec
jean-bénétique cette figure dans la
carte Vitale ça n'a pas été retenu par
le gouvernement et aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est une urgence de pouvoir le
mettre dans le dossier médical partagé
je sais que le Parlement engagé une
évaluation avec la Cour des comptes nous
verrons mais il y a un sujet extrêmement
important et j'insiste parce que tous
les termes
ont été posés à l'époque et pour la
seconde fois le Conseil constitutionnel
dans une décision il y a trois ou quatre
deux mois après à rappeler une décision
en disant elles sont contraignantes mais
il se peut dans certaines conditions que
ces directives anticipées soient
inappropriées le terme qu'on avait
retenu et c'était le question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qui a
été posée au Conseil constitutionnel par
des avocats qui remettaient en cause une
décision collégiale j'insiste collégiale
de l'équipe médicale sur une personne de
44 ans qui considérait être maintenu en
vie artificiellement et qui avait
demandé le soin l'arrêt des traitements
et sur le signe de liberté dignité de
Conseil constitutionnel a confirmer la
rédaction de cette directive anticipée
donc véritablement les directives
anticipées aujourd'hui doivent être
développées et surtout doivent être
connus et je crois qu'il faut réinvestir
en particulier sur le médecin
généraliste pour aider la rédaction
c'est ces directives anticipées
concernant la personne de confiance là
aussi
on souvient de triste d'affaires
médiatisées la personne de confiance et
quelque chose d'indispensable sur la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès
avec l'arrêt de tout et traitement
je pense que au sein de l'hôpital
cette appliqué avec les directives
l'autorité de santé cette appliquée dans
de bonnes conditions
sous réserve de vérification mais de
bonne condition par contre cette
procédure est pas appliquée dans les
EHPAD ou pas appliquer à domicile car il
est difficile parfois y compris dans la
médecine de ville d'avoir une démarche
de collégialité donc il y a
véritablement sur cette loi comme sur la
loi de 99
du travail à faire pour faire rentrer
ses lois dans la vie quotidienne de nos
bonjour dans la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens
est-ce que cette loi parce que c'est la
question règle tout non
je l'ai dit en 2016 et je le redis
aujourd'hui devant votre commission la
mission qu'on avait reçu avec jean-y de
la part du Premier ministre et du
président de la République était
d'étudier les situations le pronostic
vital est engagé à court terme
le sujet aujourd'hui si le pronostic
vital n'est pas engagé à court terme
il peut y avoir des bas et je j'arrive à
ma conclusion c'est pour cette raison
que le CNE s'est saisi de ce sujet
pour trois raisons essentielles
première raison
la démocratie parlementaire avait
introduit de débat
transpartisan
deuxièmement il y avait sur ce sujet
tension solidarité autonomie débat dans
la société
et puis on a abordé j'insiste aussi
parce que c'est essentiel ce débat dans
une situation
difficile pour l'hôpital et son
personnel
difficile c'était la précovide et le
personnel soignant en grande souffrance
et moi je tiens à le dire que les
situations difficiles qu'on a connu en
fin de vie était et essentiellement dû
essentiellement dû à cette souffrance et
c'est difficulté de prendre en charge
dans de bonnes conditions les patients
je crois qu'il faut qu'on le dise il y a
encore des inégalités territoriales et
des inégalités par établissement et la
question à laquelle il a fallu répondre
au delà de toutes les préconisations sur
lesquelles va revenir Régis sur les
soins palliatifs
c'est est-ce qu'il y a un chemin éthique
pour une aide active à mourir c'est la
question que nous avons posée
extrêmement explicitement et nous
apportons une réponse
extrêmement claire nous avons retenu
cette expression effectivement
trace deux situations très différentes
suicide assisté et euthanasie c'est la
définition que retient les soins
palliatifs sur ce sujet et donc nous
apportons un cadre et véritablement des
propositions parfaitement claires enfin
je pense qu'un sujet comme celui-là
qui touche j'allais dire à l'essentiel
pour nos concitoyens
ne doit pas
créer des polémiques j'allais dire
artificielle
je pense que le débat citoyen est
important
nous avons
été entendus où on va être entendu à la
Convention citoyenne non pas pour dire
la vérité pour dire quelle est la vie du
CCE mais je crois que ça a été redit par
votre président de l'Assemblée nationale
qui a été auditionnée par la première
ministre cette convention citoyenne doit
éclairer nos concitoyens comme les
débats nous organisons en région mais
c'est à la démocratie représentative le
moment venu de faire des arbitrages
voilà exactement très rapidement pour
que le débat puisse avoir lieu ce que je
voulais vous dire la traduction
je prends le relais merci mesdames
messieurs de cette opportunité que vous
nous donnez de présenter cet avis alors
pour ne pas être trop redondant avec ce
que vient de dire à l'inclès
peut-être je
[Musique]
vous dis qu'une des raisons
importantes
de cette auto saisine par le CCNE elle
est
dans le constat d'une part que depuis
quelques décennies mais ceci s'accroît
on assiste à une forte médicalisation de
la fin de la vie qu'on doit interroger
d'une part et d'autre part un point qui
nous appart important qui était un peu
le fil conducteur de notre réflexion
c'est que
corrélativement on progrès de la
médecine progrès indéniable aucun
d'entre nous n'aurait l'idée de remettre
en question sauf être révisionniste mais
corbativement à ces progrès on voit que
se pose aujourd'hui
des questions de confrontation longues à
la question de la fin de la vie
j'entends par là que une des
conséquences des avancées techniques et
scientifiques de la médecine quand elle
ne guérit pas elle ne le peut pas
toujours elle peut contribuer à produire
des situations de confrontation à la
maladie chronique à la dépendance
engendrer soit par la maladie soit par
l'intervention de la médecine même
parfois
et que ces réalités qui ont tendance à
augmenter
génère des situations complexes
qui posent une question éthique
fondamentale en médecine est-ce que au
motifs que l'on sait faire on doit faire
est-ce qu'on sait est-ce qu'on motive
qu'on sait faire telle ou telle
intervention ou proposer tel ou tel ou
tel traitement est-ce qu'on doit le
faire puisque parfois faire contribuer à
faire souffrir et ce qui serait à mon
avis un non-sens donc face à cette
nouvelle donne en quelque sorte de la
réalité de la fin de la vie nous
apparaissait important de renforcer
la notion qu'a évoqué à l'inclès de non
pas tellement de développement des
structures des soins palliatifs mais de
développement d'une culture
palliative d'une culture du
questionnement éthique intégré à la
pratique de l'ensemble des
professionnels
et quand j'ai bien ce mot de culture
puisqu'on miroir il y a aussi
une culture finalement de la solidarité
de nos concitoyens vis-à-vis des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
alors je vais pas revenir sur ce qui est
Alain clef je pourrais le reprendre et
le développer en disant qu'effectivement
il y a aujourd'hui je crois qu'on en est
au cinquième plan de développement du
sympathique ce qui en soi doit
interroger pourquoi en est-on encore au
constat lors de ce cinquième plan que
nous pouvions faire lors des plans
précédents et je me souviens de ces
plans que j'avais coordonnés entre 2008
et 2012 où nous nous plaignons d'un
accès aux soins apéritif encore
totalement insuffisant ou ne nous
plaignons d'une insuffisance de
formation de l'ensemble des acteurs de
santé où nous nous plaignons d'un défaut
important dans notre
environnement universitaire de recherche
interdisciplinaire pour appréhender ces
questions de fin de vie il y a quelque
chose de paradoxal à débattre alors que
l'on a peu finalement de données
produite par la recherche qui est quand
même à mon avis un élément important
et donc
pour nous c'est quelque chose
d'important qu'on intègre dans cette
notion de culture créative qui est un
sous-ensemble d'une finalement
interpellation qui est peut-être le
point fort de notre avis c'est dans
quelle mesure
pouvons-nous considérer qu'une priorité
dans le domaine de la santé au sens
large de l'acception du mot
peut être reconnu comme l'accompagnement
des personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité que c'est vulnérabilité
soit lié à l'âge qu'elle soit liées au
handicap et qu'elle soit liées ou
qu'elles soient liées à la maladie ça
nous apparaît être une condition
importante pour pouvoir envisager
une évolution du droit autour de la fin
de vie et pourquoi est-ce que ça serait
une condition c'est parce que nous avons
auditionné à plusieurs reprises et nous
avions nous-mêmes produits quelques
travaux dans d'autres avis je fais
référence la vision 128 sur les enjeux
éthiques vieillissement nous avions bien
montré que ce développement dans notre
société
sûrement chez des personnes âgées et
particulièrement chez les personnes
âgées en situation de dépendance et
d'altération de leur autonomie parfois
ce que l'on nomme un sentiment
d'indignité c'est à dire qu'il y a
quelque chose qui fait que des personnes
se sentent être finalement
un problème plutôt qu'une personne un
poids une charge pour autrui et il nous
apparaît qu'il y a là quelque chose qui
renvoie au regard que porte notre
société sur ces sur ces personnes sur
ces situations on a le même écho le même
discours cher certains malades lourds
chroniques qui finalement sont en
situation de dépendance peu importe
l'âge qui est le leur finalement
pourquoi nous assistons sur ce point
à mon avis un élément central de notre
avis est-ce que politiquement nous
pouvons avoir
dans notre pays un engagement fort pour
prioriser
la question de l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
ça nous apparaît évidemment important
si oui
et pour éviter ce que Alain clès nommé
une loi sèche je retiens tout le temps
ton
façon dont tu présentes Tesla une loi
sèche qui serait s'intégrerait pas dans
une politique plus large
si oui il nous est apparu important de
réfléchir comme Alain le disait pourquoi
et en quoi et à quel moment une
évolution du droit pourrait être
pertinente au plan éthique c'est le seul
prisme au travers duquel on discute et
donc pour reprendre ce que disait à
l'inclès effectivement on voit bien à
mesure que notre
médecine contribue à produire des
situations de longue confrontation avec
la fin de vie que nous sommes confrontés
dans le champ de la santé dans le champ
de la société a des demandes d'aide
activement qui ne sont pas nombreuses
mais qui existent et peu importe
finalement à fréquence puisqu'on on
s'interroge tout le temps pour savoir si
cette fréquence nécessite qu'on y
réfléchisse oui quel que soit la
fréquence elle nécessite qu'on y
réfléchisse elle nécessite qu'on y
réfléchisse si on considère qu'une
demande doit être écoutée
une demande d'aide active Amory à mourir
et signifiante elle signifie pas
forcément une volonté de mourir mais
elle signifie une souffrance et donc un
des enjeux majeurs pour nous c'est que
c'est demande puissent être en écouter
entendu accompagner alors on a
auditionné quelques chercheurs sur ce
point-là qui montre que effectivement il
a encore je rentre pas dans les les
questions de fréquence ce n'est pas ça
le problème mais la très grande majorité
des demandes s'étioles ou disparaissent
lorsqu'on a une écoute auprès de ces
personnes ou qu'on répond à ce qui peut
motiver de l'intérieur une telle demande
une douleur réfractaire un symptôme
réfractaire ou si l'on apporte une forme
de considération je reviens sur cette
notion de sentiment d'indignité qu'il ne
serait pas digne de confondre avec une
indemnité me semble-t-il et donc il nous
apparaît important d'avoir cette
démarche là
une fois que nous avons le sentiment
qu'une demande au terme d'un
accompagnement au terme d'échanges avec
une équipe et des proches correspond
effectivement à la volonté de la
personne
volonté d'une aide active à mourir se
pose la question de distinguer
effectivement la question de
l'assistance aux suicide de celle de
l'euthanasie de forme d'aide active à
mourir mais de réalité assez
fondamentalement différentes du point de
vue éthique en tout cas
dans le premier cas en effet donc il
s'agit de rendre possible dans des
conditions que je vous ai présentées
précisé qui sont assez détaillés dans
notre dans notre avis c'est à dire
rendre possible lorsque nous avons
acquis la conviction de façon
interdisciplinaire qu'une demande
correspond effectivement à l'expression
de la volonté de mourir d'une personne
d'une personne rendre possible l'accès à
un produit létal c'est la question de
l'assistance au suicide on s'est
beaucoup référé à d'autres expériences
assez peu de travaux de recherche quand
même pour analyser ces expériences mais
en l'occurrence on a beaucoup travaillé
sur les expériences de l'État d'origon
qui nous semble intéressant dans le
cadre de l'assistance au suicide et il
nous a semblés intéressants d'analyser
et de d'interpréter le fait que une
partie de
demande qui semble correspondre à la
volonté des personnes qui rentrent dans
l'état de l'Orégon dans le cadre
personne atteinte d'une maladie grave
incurable dont l'espérance de vie est
évaluée à moyen terme moins de 6 mois
dans cet état
un tiers la moitié de ses demandes qui
ont été faites par les personnes
n'aboutissent pas au fait que la
personne va chercher le produit létal
auquel elle est autorisée d'avoir accès
et un tiers des personnes qui sont allés
chercher ce produit létal ne l'absorbe
pas c'est intéressant pour nous de
l'analyser fondamentalement puisque ça
et c'est quelque chose qui est lors
d'une interprétation mais qui a des
chances d'être assez juste entre
guillemets ça signifie là encore que
lorsque la personne a la possibilité de
prendre le même le produit létal elle ne
le fait pas toujours elle le fait
parfois
et qu'il y a à respecter une forme
d'ambivalence ultime chez les personnes
il y a quelques travaux qui interrogent
ces personnes pour comprendre pourquoi
elles ne vont pas au bout de cet acte et
bien parce que elles sont envahies par
quelque chose qu'on appelle
l'ambivalence le doute enfin peu importe
ça nous semble important de l'entendre
parce que c'est différent quand on se
tourne vers la question de l'euthanasie
le fait d'avoir un tiers qui administre
un produit létal où là finalement cette
ambivalence peut être escamotée en
quelque sorte je ne dis pas que
on rentre pas dans la caricature autour
de les pays qui ont des pénalisés le
l'euthanasie et des travaux qui ont été
faits vous les connaissez à mon avis
s'agit pas pour nous d'entrer dans cette
dimension là mais fondamentalement il y
a une différence assez profonde que je
viens de vous nommer puis il y en a une
deuxième qui nous semble importante
c'est l'application du du médecin dans
cette affaire de l'aide actifs à mourir
une question qui se pose
évidemment c'est de savoir si on doit où
on peut
considérer l'aide active à mourir comme
un soin
se discutable c'est discuter vous
entendrez vous avez entendu des avis
différents tours de tout cela mais il y
a une différence me semble-t-il tout de
même de ce point de vue entre là encore
le suicide assisté et le l'euthanasie
puisque dans le premier cas
l'intervention du médecin et si on se
réfère à cette étape qui a produit
beaucoup de travaux consiste à
confirmer que la personne est bien dans
la situation qui relève d'un éventuel
droit dans le deuxième cas le médecin
lorsque c'est un médecin qui est
sollicité est un acteur de cette affaire
là
et il nous a parlé important aussi
d'être sur cette nuance qui n'en est pas
qui est plus qu'une nuance d'être très
attentif on voit bien on l'a entendu
lors de nos auditions combien il y a une
véritable résistance légitime me
semble-t-il à entendre à considérer que
un homme un professionnel de santé
pourrait avoir dans une confusion de son
rôle la possibilité de tout faire pour
aider la personne à ne pas souffrir
restons dans le domaine des sympathiques
et administrer un produit létal que ça
fasse difficulté ça me semble pas
anormal et donc aussi peut-être surtout
dans cette idée que
cette question de l'assistance au
suicide chez les personnes
qui ne relèvent pas d'une dimension d'un
désir de mort lorsque l'espérance de vie
à court terme auquel cas le droit nous
semble le droit actuel à quelques
peut-être quelques aménagements
réglementaires qui évoquaient
éventuellement à l'inclès mais nous
semble être
satisfaisant etc on est dans un champ
produit parfois par là la médecine
elle-même ou la question de
l'assistance aux suicide peut se poser
il nous apparaît en d'autres termes et
pour terminer mon propos que
effectivement il y a des enjeux éthiques
différents dans ce cadre là entre la
question d'assistance au suicide et
celle de l'euthanasie
autre chose que les questions qui se
posent nous ne sommes pas à votre place
on en est bien heureux d'ailleurs
peut-être parfois mais il nous a parlé
important de faire état de ces questions
éthiques de nature assez différentes qui
se posent dans ces dans ce cadre-là et
puis je répète parce que c'est peut-être
le point central de notre avis qui n'a
pas été retenu comme étant le plus
central par les médias parfois
cette notion de
[Musique]
d'envisager une évolution du droit dans
un contexte qui serait celui d'un choix
politique fort et affirmé de
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité nous
apparaître quelque chose de fondamental
on imagine effectivement le MES usage
qui pourrait être fait d'un droit qui
serait déconnecté d'une politique de
santé dans ce registre là il y a pas
besoin de rentrer peut-être dans plus de
détails il me semble-t-il voilà
merci messieurs avant de donner la
parole à mes collègues je souhaiterais
poser une question à chacun et chacune
d'entre vous
d'abord madame degrés du loup donc
effectivement comme je l'ai dit dans mon
introduction et quelques quelques
membres du CCNE ont émis des
quelques réserves sur cet avis qui ont
été publiés en annexe de cet avis donc
je voudrais savoir quels sont les quels
sont la nature de ces réserves émises
je voulais demander à Régis Aubry lors
de préciser
vous parler d'ambivalence sur sur le
suicide assisté vous avez cité les
l'exemple de l'Orégon est-ce que vous
pouvez me préciser parce que je suis pas
sûr d'avoir bien compris quelque part
votre
je ne veux pas mal comprendre est-ce que
le suicide assisté
protégerait selon vous plus
l'ambivalence du malade que le thanazi
ce que j'ai bien compris et ce que donc
si j'ai bien compris est-ce que ça
suppose que effectivement
la
l'intervention dans cet accompagnement
d'un médecin
évidemment
chacun le sait dans votre avis
évidemment la préciser que la clause de
conscience s'applique
en aucun cas et nulle part dans le monde
un médecin est obligé de procéder à une
aide active à mourir mais si j'entends
votre raisonnement donc l'ambivalence du
malade serait
moins respecté dans le cadre d'une
euthanasie et de l'intervention d'un
médecin et puis je voulais demander à
l'inclès quel
bilan c'est vrai que une des éléments
très importants de la loi c'est
l'introduction donc de la sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès quel
bilan pouvez-vous dresser de du recours
aujourd'hui à la sédation profonde et
continue dans quelle mesure ce droit
est-il aujourd'hui réellement garantie
et selon vous quelles sont les
principales difficultés aujourd'hui pour
mettre en œuvre cette sédation profonde
et continue
madame
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement donc nous sommes 8 membres
du CCNE à avoir écrit une réserve qui
est une réserve à
une partie de la vie parce que nous
endossons 90% de la vie nous partageons
pleinement toute l'analyse qui est faite
en particulier de
l'insuffisance de déploiement des soins
palliatifs et voilà toute la partie
analytique en fait est complètement
endossée et notre réserve porte très
précisément sur la recommandation EB qui
est la possibilité d'une éventuelle
évolution législative vers l'aide active
à mourir et notre réserve porte et
j'insiste là-dessus pas sur c'est pas
une réserve de principe c'est une
réserve de temporalité en fait nous nous
pensons que
il y a des pré-requis avant d'imaginer
une éventuelle évolution dans le sens
que quand expliquer à l'anglais et
régissait Aubry et que c'est pré-requis
sont très précis pour nous ils sont ils
sont trois il nous semble absolument
indispensable que les dispositifs
législatifs qui existent aujourd'hui en
France soit connue qui soit appliqué et
qui soit évalués et on se réjouit que
votre commission mais justement avant
pas mal sur ce point-là
notre deuxième prérequis c'est que toute
personne aujourd'hui en France est accès
à des soins palliatifs de qualité et un
accompagnement global et humain de
qualité et on a bien vu avec la partie
analytique qu'on en est très loin
puisqu'il y a 20 départements dans
lesquels c'est soins palliatifs ne sont
pas disponibles et notre troisième
prérequis c'est aussi un prérequis de
recherche moi je suis chercheur je parle
ici en tant que chercheur
bien que quelques recherches existent
elles sont encore très très peu
nombreuses et il nous semble trop peu
nombreuses pour bien comprendre avant
d'avancer sur ce point qui est
évidemment un point grave au sens plein
du terme il nous semble important de
comprendre d'où viennent ces demandes
d'aide actives à mourir dans quelle
situation elles sont exprimées et puis
quels sont leurs effets et quels sont
les effets dans les pays où l'aide
active à mourir autorisé sur sur aussi
les proches et les soignants et
peut-être la société il nous semble que
tant qu'on a passé trois prérequis il y
a vraiment un risque de renonce pas
important d'avancer sur une sur une
ouverture de la loi à l'aide active à
mourir et un renoncement qui en fait
vient précisément du risque que l'aide
activa mourir soit demander par défaut
par défaut de accès à un accompagnement
de qualité alors je vais être très
rapide mais nous nous soulevons cinq
quatre inquiétudes la première c'est
celle dont je viens de vous parler la
possibilité d'un recours par défaut et
qui touchera nous en sommes persuadés
les personnes les plus défavorisées les
plus pauvres parce que ce sont celles
qui auront le moins accès justement
quand on a des ressources sociales
financières etc on arrive toujours
finalement à trouver des soins
palliatifs quand on en a pas on du coup
on peut se retrouver plus dans une
situation où on va demander l'aide à
mourir parce que parce qu'on parce qu'on
pèse trop sur les autres que et que on
n'a pas accès à l'accompagnement qui est
rassurant le deuxième risque c'est
justement le message envoyé aux
personnes malades ou fragiles ou
handicapés qu'il pourrait y avoir des
vies qui valent pas d'être vécu et il
nous semble que il y a tant qu'on n'a
pas accès à ses soins palliatifs pour
tous de qualité le risque d'un recours
pour ces personnes là les plus
vulnérables qui ne voudraient pas peser
sur les autres voilà d'y avoir recours
et je reviens sur mon premier point le
troisième risque c'est le message envoyé
à la société il nous semble
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
collectivement encore mener suffisamment
le débat de qu'est-ce que c'est que
accompagner les gens en fin de vie nous
nous réjouissons de l'ouverture de la
convention citoyenne mais il nous semble
que c'est c'est insuffisant il faut que
ce soit un débat qui touche tout le
monde qui touche à tous les niveaux dans
les familles dans les EHPAD dans toutes
commune et que tant que nous nous sommes
pas posés collectivement ces questions
là nous ne serons pas accompagnés les
personnes de nos familles de nos
entourages vers vers une fin de vie
apaisée
et voilà et du coup que
le comment dire l'élargissement d'une
loi dans ce dans une situation où on ne
sait pas suffisamment poser les bonnes
questions pourraient être
contre-productive et puis dernier risque
c'est le message envoyé aux soignants
dans un moment où notre système de santé
traverse une crise très grave Régis
Aubry a bien souligné la difficulté que
ça peut représenter pour des soignants
de poser ses actes-là est-ce que c'est
l'urgence aujourd'hui de de d'ouvrir à
cette évolution là alors que les
soignants sont en attente de beaucoup
d'autres évolutions qu'ils ne voient pas
venir et donc voilà donc il nous semble
que ça pourrait être très mal perçu par
les soignants que on avance sur un point
alors qu'il demande beaucoup d'avancer
sur d'autres points sur lesquels on
n'avance pas donc voilà je
là mais vous voyez que notre réserve
c'est une réserve vraiment de de
pré-requis nous demandons que il y ait
une application des lois existantes et
en particulier de la loi Clayes léonity
une amélioration globalement des
conditions de l'accompagnement de la fin
de vie et aussi des conditions
sociétales et de notre façon collective
d'y penser et puis une amélioration des
connaissances avant d'avancer
je vous remercie
alors sur la question de l'ambivalence
que vous me posiez
je dézoome
pour
vous rappeler combien
autour de cette question de
l'élatives à mourir on est assez clair
lorsqu'on n'est pas concerné c'est à
dire qu'on peut avoir une opinion assez
assez
tranchées argumenté le propos n'est pas
là lorsqu'on n'est pas concerné mais les
travaux là qu'on a pu lire dont et qu'on
a pu et les personnes qu'on a pu
additionner autour de tout cela et je me
rappelle aussi de travaux un peu plus
personnel que j'ai mené avec Lynette
d'ailleurs sur ces cassias montre que
plus quelqu'un est confronté à la
question de sa propre finitude plus
entre
des désirs qui peuvent se poser et plus
il avance dans sa maladie plus la
fréquence des oscillations augmente si
je peux dire les choses comme ça dans
une même phrase quand on s'occupe de
patients
atteints de maladies graves avancées qui
éventuellement formule des demandes
comme celle-ci on peut avoir dans la
dans la dans le même discours des des
demandes contradictoires donc c'est
important de respecter cette dimension
de l'ambivalence et il semble mais je
vous disais que c'est une interprétation
de données il semble que lorsque la
personne est en possibilité en capacité
elle-même de prendre un produit létal
elle est là encore une forme
d'ambivalence qui fait qu'elle
éventuellement alors qu'il apparaissait
justifier qu'elle y est taxée elle ne le
prenne pas ce qui différencie c'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure cette
forme d'aide active à mourir de la
question de l'euthanasie ça nous
apparaît important en tout cas nous sur
un plan éthique d'être très respectueux
de cette dimension de l'ambivalence de
la personne jusqu'au bien entendu je
sais pas si c'est plus clair ce que je
vous dis non pas vraiment parce que donc
ça supposerait que dans le cadre d'un
accompagnement médical dans un cadre de
thanazie c'est ambivalence la question
que je pose c'est
en quoi cette ambivalence possible
et cette volonté voilà affichée parce
que effectivement il y a des situations
d'ambivalence il y a des il y a des
déterminations aussi on peut pas on peut
pas les nier mais je ne vois pas en quoi
l'intervention d'un médecin pour être
clair dans ce processus remettrai en
cause cette ambivalence puisque c'est
pas le médecin qui va pousser
allez bâti va mourir et je ne vois pas
en quoi cette ambivalence et donc
finalement quelque part le respect ou
non respect de la volonté finale du
malade serait atténué dans le cadre
d'une euthanasie et quelque part si je
vous entends le suicide assisté serait
plus respectueuse de cette ambivalence
que j'ai du mal à comprendre
je vais essayer de vous expliquer de
façon encore plus claire lorsque vous
avez eu quelqu'un il peut plus exprimer
son ambivalence
et pourtant dans les deux cas vous étiez
convaincu que ça demande correspondait à
sa volonté dans un cas vous lui donnez
la possibilité de prendre un produit
létal dans le deuxième cas convaincu que
vous êtes je ne porte pas de jugement
sur ces sur ces questions là vous vous
en rendez compte mais vous administrez
le produit vital en tant que tierce
personne vous engagez votre propre
responsabilité dans le fait
d'administrer un produit létal
vous comprenez que dans le premier cas
la personne a encore une possibilité
d'exprimer son violence et de ne pas
absorber son produit létal dans le
deuxième cas puisque vous l'avez
euthanasié elle ne le peut plus
oui mais c'est à la demande du malade
mais je sais pas comment il faut que je
vous le dise mais j'ai essayé de vous
exprimer monsieur la différence qu'il y
a entre une demande et l'expression de
la volonté et dans le chemin qui est le
nôtre nous essayons de comprendre tout
ce qui différencie une demande avec la
réalité de la volonté de la personne
c'est beaucoup plus complexe si toutes
les demandes correspondaient à la
volonté des personnes d'ailleurs nous
aurions souvent des confrontations à ces
questions là ce que j'ai cette vous dire
c'est qu'une demande même à un stade
très avancé peut exprimer autre chose
que la volonté de mourir et que il est
du devoir du professionnel de santé ou
du professionnel qui sera en charge de
cette question de l'aide à mourir d'être
très vigilant dans cette dimension là je
pense que c'est c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important me semble-t-il
la demande n'est qui vaut pas à la
volonté ça m'apparaît quelque chose
d'important et quand vous êtes un
professionnel de santé ça signifie
quelque chose ce que je vous dis là
parce que probablement parce que je suis
moi confronté à ces questions assez
régulièrement je peux vous dire
qu'effectivement on est parfois
convaincu même collectivement puisque on
va jusqu'à dire il faudrait même que
cette volonté
présumée soit partagée en termes de
questionnements avec d'autres
professionnels que le médecin avec les
proches pour s'assurer que la demande
correspond avec la volonté mais même
lorsque vous avez un collectif qui là
cette fois on a le sentiment réellement
que la demande exprime la volonté de la
personne et bien il y a encore des
doutes qui s'expriment par l'agir de la
personne
je sais pas si c'est plus clair
maintenant
je vais je vais laisser la parole à mes
collègues simplement
j'entends la nuance demande volonté
dans le cas de l'Oregon pour être clair
il y a un moment il y a une volonté qui
s'exprime elle rentre dans le cadre ou
pas le médecin prescrit il y a une
demande qui s'exprime oui oui il y a une
demande qui s'exprime mais faites
attention de pas confondre demande des
volonté il y a une demande qui s'exprime
si ça rentre dans le cadre de la loi le
médecin prescrit fait une ordonnance
voilà en respectant cette demande et
donc le médecin
valide cette demande et donc ensuite la
personne se retrouve j'allais dire face
à elle-même et face à son produit
et c'est là où je quelque part on laisse
finalement le malade face à son produit
et face à sa demande et face à sa
volonté seul parfois
et et c'est cela que je
n'arrive pas complètement à comprendre
je peux comprendre les problèmes
d'éthique de mais ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est en quoi cette demande serait
mieux respecter et plus attentive en
faisant
quelque part une prescription par un
médecin
plutôt que de participer à une aide
active à mourir je ne vois pas en quoi
faire une ordonnance qu'un médecin fasse
une ordonnance serait plus respectueux
de l'ambivalence que dans le cadre d'une
euthanasie j'ai du mal à comprendre je
ne comprends pas
juste un petit
à votre avis pourquoi la personne
parfois ne prend pas le produit métal
à votre avis parce que du coup je vous
renvoie la question
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une part non
négligeable des personnes qui ont cette
possibilité de le prendre ce produit
quand elles entrent dans un cadre légal
qui est pas prescrime enfin qui est
autorisé dans dans le cadre de l'Orégon
ne l'absorbe pas comment on peut
expliquer le fait qu'elle ne l'absorbe
pas alors que tous les critères confus
vers la possibilité
je pourrais dire qu'il en est de même
pour l'euthanasie puisqu'il y a beaucoup
de personnes qui renoncent à leur
demande enfin je veux dire en Belgique
il y a des personnes qui renoncent à
leur à leur demande enfin c'est c'est
fréquent alors tous ceux qui ne
demandent tous ceux qui demandent une
euthanasie
ne vont pas jusqu'au bout Président vous
motorisez
je répondrai à votre question bien
entendu
mais je pense que la notion demande et
volonté est essentielle quel que soit la
position qu'on peut avoir et
je crois qu'on l'a rédigé extrêmement
précisément on a abordé assistante au
suicide et euthanasie et pourquoi on a
abordé euthanasie
parce que on a considéré je crois qu'on
l'a écrit noir sur blanc qui n'aurait
pas été éthique d'autre part de pas
l'aborder lorsqu'une personne est
autonome pour exprimer une volonté et
physiquement on peut pas faire le geste
c'est c'est écrit pratiquement toute
cette façon mais entre la demande
et la volonté il doit y avoir un travail
collégial on ne peut pas
passer sous silence des interrogations
de cette personne peut avoir dans le
cadre d'un contexte familial donc dans
le cas de relations et c'est vrai que
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
tenu très compliqué si on veut avoir le
consentement éclairé de la personne pour
le coup il faut que cette demande
s'appuie sur une volonté et c'est le
travail que les gens moi je crois que
c'est extrêmement important et j'allais
dire ça rentre totalement dans tout le
travail que les lois et que le CCE en
termes de de d'avis ont pu formuler ça
c'est la première chose que je veux dire
la deuxième chose et je dis aussi
clairement
nous posons pas
soin palliatifs et aide à mourir
ça serait une faute et moi vous me
permettrez je peux le faire si je
connais bien la personne et je le fais
de mon Régis c'est pas pour rien
pour les biens
a eu
nous a soutenu dans la loi 2016 a fait
un travail de conviction extrêmement
fort
a eu tous les soins palliatifs
qui pouvait être disponible
donc la solidarité
de la nation à jouer pleinement
malgré cela à un moment donné
à la exprimé
sa demande et je suppose que le travail
collégial
a eu lieu
et cette demande
à aboutit donc nous posons pas les
choses vous savez
plus je travaille sur ces sujets là plus
plus
j'ai la conviction qu'il faut pas
globaliser les choses que chaque cas est
un cas personnel mais la question qui se
pose maintenant pour notre pays à
travers de législateur c'est est-ce que
cette demande
d'autonomie
doit se traduire par un acte législatif
c'est ça le problème
on a tranché sur la loi Kouchner en 2002
l'arrêt du traitement
là encore quelqu'un qui est diabétique
qui demande la raison traitement ça
suppose des discussions entre la
personne et l'équipe médicale
pluridisciplinaire donc voilà moi je
crois que et sur le tanaisie n'a pas
voulu exclure
c'est le V dans la législation française
l'interdiction de donner la mort c'est
ça qui
et nous disons qu'il y a deux voix
possible
la voix législative qui est levé cette
interdiction et ce que j'appelle la voix
Badinter qui est de dire les sons juges
à un moment d'arbitrer les choses voilà
moi je me ressente sur la vie du CCN
pour que les choses soient parfaitement
claires pour vous et celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent sur la sédation profonde
et continue vous avez raison président
elle ne peut pas s'appliquer
correctement sur l'ensemble du
territoire elle peut s'appliquer au sein
des hôpitaux extrêmement difficiles
parce que la collégialité ne peut pas
fonctionner comme vous avez qu'un
médecin coordonnateur et une infirmière
qui entreprise dans les EHPAD et ça ne
peut pas très difficilement jouer jouer
à domicile donc la question la question
que vous posez est réel
j'ajoute qu'il y a eu
au moment de cette loi et je passe sur
le contrôle du Régis qui a fait à
l'époque un travail important de
conviction le mot continu à poser un
problème un sujet pour les médecins et
les ateliers de soins palliatifs sur la
notion de continuité dans le cadre des
prolongements de malgré tout nous avons
pu
arriver
à formuler tel quel la proposition et
j'ajoute aussi l'arrêt de tous les
traitements vous souvenez du débat c'est
pour ça que la notion de court terme est
extrêmement importante l'arête tout est
traitements suite à une décision du
Conseil d'État et un accord en
commission mixte parlementaire est
introduit que l'alimentation et
l'hydratation artificielle constituée un
traitement et non pas un soin voilà les
précisions que je voulais apporter par
rapport à
merci je donne la parole à Caroline Fiat
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement quelques questions
monsieur classe donc nous faisons
l'évaluation de votre loi si
x ans quand même
6 ans plus tard
on voit que et là elle n'est pas
accessible à tout les Français
que mettriez-vous
en plus dans votre dans la loi du
Parlement qui porte votre nom
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il manque
quelque chose
avec le recul pour qu'elle soit
accessible à tout le monde vous nous
avez parlé d'une infirmière qui avait
fait un parcours complet et qui avait
réussi à vulgariser les directives
anticipées
savez-vous s'il existe un document écrit
ou si elle le fait de manière orale en
discussion de directives anticipée ce
qu'on en parle beaucoup
Monsieur Aubry l'aide d'active à mourir
peut-elle être considéré comme un soin
c'est ce que vous nous avez dit si on
considère qu'une toilette mortuaire est
un soin
euh que la sédation profonde est un soin
pour pourquoi se poser cette question
comment expliquer vous que nous soyons
toujours adressé le même constat qu'il y
a 10 ans et pour vous quels sont les
facteurs de blocage et pour vous deux
vous avez beaucoup parlé des personnes
en situation de
vulnérabilité et Monsieur oui vous avez
dit une très belle phrase une demande
d'aide active à mourir signifie une
souffrance qui doit absolument être
entendue et j'ai envie de penser que
c'est pareil pour la sédation pour la
demande de sédation profonde
cuite de la souffrance des personnes
vulnérables ce sera tout pour moi
oui sur la partie de la je crois qu'il
faut qu'on se mette d'accord
un soin
je veux dire
existe jusqu'au dernier moment
je crois que c'était essentiel nous
confondons pas soin et traitement
un traitement peut être interrompu les
soins vont jusqu'au bout
moi sur cette infirmier
je peux demander à l'hôpital de fournir
les documents qu'elle
met à disposition du personnel soignant
et des des personnes qui sont à
l'hôpital les deux parce que je crois
qu'il y a un travail sur les deux mais à
la limite vous pourriez éventuellement
le dictionner ça serait peut-être j'en
sais rien moi c'est pas moi c'est à VOUS
président et aux rapporteur de voir moi
je peux vous donner toutes les
coordonnées
qu'est-ce qu'il y aurait
à modifier avant de modifier
comment
pouvoir mieux l'appliquer
sur les directives anticipées
il y a eu
les prescriptions dans Haute Autorité de
santé qui donne le câble le fil
conducteur
un citoyen ne peut pas rédiger si
directives anticipées sans un appui
médical moi je pense que c'est et la
deuxième élément bien faire comprendre
c'est qu'il est directive anticipé on
les écrit pas une fois pour tout
elles peuvent être modifiées à tout
moment
une personne en bonne santé on retrouve
le débat une personne en bonne santé
écrit c'est directive anticipée puis une
personne à qui on annonce un diagnostic
particulièrement grave peut avoir à ce
moment-là une vision différente de ces
directives anticipées ça c'est aussi une
évolution de la loi car on ne pouvait
dans la précédente loi je pense que le
contrôle sur votre contrôle ne modifiez
que tous les trois ans les directives
anticipées donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
modifier
les termes parce que je considère que
situation inappropriée est importante
je pense on donne plus d'autonomie à la
personne dans sa volonté l'expression de
sa volonté mais il faut que l'équipe
médicale garde des possibilités à un
moment ou un autre en toute transparence
de dire non la situation de la personne
ne correspond pas aux directives
anticipées qui ont été rédigées et je
crois que c'est très important c'est
très important car il peut y avoir
le cas qu'on le cas quand le Conseil
constitutionnel a eu à prendre une
décision illustre bien illustre bien
cela
le risque sur la fellation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès
c'est qu'elle soit mais je parle tout de
contrôle
qu'elle soit appliquée j'allais dire
hors champ
signe sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès est appliqué lorsque le
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à court
terme je pense que cette proposition
cette disposition
[Musique]
ne correspond pas y compris on
préconisations de la Haute Autorité de
Santé donc moi je me suis efforcé de
dire tout à l'heure que par rapport à
cette loi il y a son application qui
quand même limité à l'hôpital très peu
développé dans les EHPAD ou à domicile
et deuxièmement je vous ai dit très
clairement que cette loi
ne règle pas tous les sujets il peut y
avoir des pronostics vitaux engagés à
moyen terme et la sédation profonde est
constituée si j'en crois les médecins et
toutes les études qui ont été faites ne
correspond pas
voilà et la dernière question qui se
pose
c'est ça c'est cette autonomie
est-ce que
cette étape est franchie par la société
c'est dans l'autonomie ou pas c'est ça
la question aujourd'hui qui se pose
c'est pas les lois de ce contredisent
pas toutes les lois depuis 20 ans ou un
sens ou un palliatif personne à conteste
couchèrent personne ne contexte
troisième loi con sous-estime et Régis a
eu raison tout à l'heure de l'évoquer
les progrès de la médecine peuvent
conduire à des situations inacceptables
pour le patient et l'obstination
déraisonnable est quelque chose
d'important mais l'obstination
déraisonnable
peut conduire à un moment à une décision
d'arrêter tous les traitements c'est la
QPC qui a que le Conseil constitutionnel
agit donc c'est extrêmement c'est
extrêmement important mais je veux dire
toutes ces lois étaient dans une logique
ça veut dire la correspondent
parler d'aide activement
ne s'oppose pas à tout ce travail qui
est indispensable pas de loi sèche on
l'a dit répéter mais on change de
paradis
et contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire
certaines publications il n'y a pas
rupture de vue et je parle à côté d'un
spécialiste du comité nationalétique
rupture par rapport aux autres positions
du CCNE
l'avant-dernière position du CNE par les
situations exceptionnelles c'était ça
qui avait été retenu on essaye à travers
cet avis de traduire
s'il législateur décide d'intervenir de
traduire le contenu de ces situations
exceptionnelles je sais pas si je suis
clair mais j'essaye d'être voilà
par rapport à la question que vous me
posiez en quoi finalement
injecter un produit létal ne serait pas
ne pourrait pas être considéré comme un
soin j'ai bien compris votre question
c'est ça
oui
écoutez c'est une question qui se pose
comme je vous le disais c'est une
question qui se pose en tout cas ce
n'est pas un soin anodin puisque il n'y
a pas de retour
on doit le considérer comme un soin
au terme d'un accompagnement on accepte
qu'une personne
je suicide
et quelque chose qui à mon avis relève
de ce qu'on a appelé dans cet avis la
solidarité et le respect de l'autonomie
je reviens sur ce qu'on échangeait tout
à l'heure
qu'on soit l'acteur de l'administration
du produit létal réduit de mon point de
vue de notre point de vue la part
d'autonomie de la personne et cette
question de considérer
l'injection d'un produit vital sans être
dans les caricatures je lis la et
ailleurs des fois des propos quand je
trouve mais pose question c'est c'était
heureusement d'ailleurs je fais
référence éventuellement un arène la
banalité du mal en vous disant cela
heureusement qu'injecter un produit
létal pose question un professionnel de
la santé
vous imaginez que ça n'en pose pas où là
ça nous poserait une vraie question
sur
la deuxième question que vous vous
posiez pourquoi pourquoi rien n'a changé
depuis
ils ont écouté c'est ce qu'on a essayé
d'analyser en se disant finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il fait que l'empilement
des plantes ne produit pas
ce que l'on est d'accord comme comme
objectif
alors il y a des explications derrière
ça qui vous sont vous seront donnés par
des collègues qui sont en charge du plan
actuel mais moi j'ai le souvenir tout de
même
que certains financements accordés
effectivement dans le cas des plans ont
été correctement attribués par l'État
aux établissements aux ARS
ensuite les priorités ont été discutées
que certains établissements qui ont bien
reçu des RS les financements ne les ont
pas utilisé à cela dans un dans un
système je fais pas de procès
d'attention où il y avait des choix à
faire et des priorités à faire et
précisément
un des enjeux pour nous
c'est de nous demander si
dans un contexte ou à ce jour je pense
que nous pouvons dire que nous n'avons
plus en matière de santé peut-être dans
d'autres domaines je parle vraiment dans
ce domaine nous n'avons peut-être plus
les moyens de toutes nos ambitions nous
ne pouvons pas forcément accompagner
tout les demandes tout les progrès
toutes les possibilités qui sont
offertes par développement de la
médecine peut-être que dans ce contexte
là il sait ce que j'ai essayé d'évoquer
tout à l'heure il s'agit de se dire
qu'est-ce qui est prioritaire dans une
société au plan de la santé et est-ce
que l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation vulnérabilité n'est pas la
priorité dans une société démocratique
comme la nôtre je termine sur ce point
par un autre aspect qu'on a beaucoup
discuté dans le cadre de cet avis et
dans un avis qui suit sur la crise du
système de soins
c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait que les choses ne
bougent pas mais peut-être d'ailleurs
c'était évoqué je crois récemment dans
un discours du président de la
République mais là la façon dont on
valorise les actes actuellement dans le
champ de la santé qu'on parle de
médecine libérale
médecine à l'acte ou qu'on parle de
médecine hospitalière tarification de
l'activité
ne valorise pas de fait écoute de la
souffrance des malades qui prend du
temps qui est chronophage qui est
énergivore en quelque sorte ne favorise
pas
la place de la délibération collective
et finalement on ne les valorisant pas
les dévalorise et je pense qu'on est
loin de pouvoir et qu'un levier je cite
à la formation tout à l'heure pour
développer une culture palative mais un
autre levier c'est de se donner moyen de
valoriser c'est tant qui sont des temps
de base dans le soin
écouter des personnes malades ça ne
m'apparaît quelque chose de fondamental
ça devrait être valorisé indépendamment
du statut
de celui qui écoute de mon point de vue
et puis dernier point pardon
dernier point sur la souffrance des
personnes moi j'attire votre attention
sur des travaux qui ont été publiés ces
derniers bien entendu dans dans les
demandes de d'Activa mourir on a mais je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord avec ça
évidemment une demande d'activer un
mourir qui serait motivé par un une
douleur qui ne serait pas traitée c'est
la douleur qu'il faut traiter enfin
c'est la confort qu'il faut essayer de
traiter je pense réellement qu'il y a
des progrès qui ont été faits tout de
même depuis quelques années sur ce point
mais il y en a encore à faire et je vous
le disais tout à l'heure à mesure qu'on
fabrique des situations complexes en
médecine on fabrique des nouveaux types
de douleurs que nous avons du mal à
traiter aussi parfois mais parfois
la demande n'est pas liée à la
souffrance des paliers à une douleur ou
un symptôme d'inconfort elle est liée
alors elle peut être liée à une phase de
dépression qu'on connaît bien dans ce
temps il faut s'acharner à s'assurer que
ce n'est pas une phase dépressive mais
j'insiste parce que les travaux c'est
récents montrent au fond émerger la
notion de souffrance existentielle
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui au terme
de leur existence interrogent la
question du sens de la vie de leur vie
pas de la vie en général de la leur
d'ailleurs elle nous dit ces personnes
ne parlaient pas du sens de ma vie vous
ne pouvez pas le connaître c'est moi qui
peut en parler et cette souffrance là
surtout quand elle s'inscrit dans une
durée qui est un peu longue
elle peut générer une demande d'arrêter
de vivre entre guillemets cette question
de la souffrance est quelque chose de
très extrêmement complexe on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui ou ça serait être très
prétentieux ce qu'il ne faut surtout pas
être dans ce contexte là qu'on sait
aujourd'hui traiter toutes les
souffrances très honnêtement un peu
d'humilité ne fait pas de mal autour de
tout cela
oui pour plonger la question que vous me
posez tout à l'heure
je crois que j'ai un regret par rapport
à la loi de 2016 c'est pas avoir abordé
correctement les soins palliatifs
on a toujours raisonné y compris en 2016
d'un point de vue quantitatif
je pense que c'est une erreur il y a eu
des plans très bien il manque toujours
de l'argent
je pense
que aujourd'hui alors que la mort la fin
de vie c'est médicalisée
il n'y a pas dans le projet de nos
facultés de médecine
dans le projet de nos établissements
une politique de médecine de la personne
je préfère parler de soin
d'accompagnement que ce soit un
palliatif parce que soit palliatifs pour
nos concitoyens
quand il y a plus rien à faire je
considère et ça se fait
que lorsqu'il y a un diagnostic qui est
posé d'un cancer tout autre pathologie
cette médecine de la personne doit se
mettre en route
alors est-ce qu'on a des leviers
prions de la République a évoqué un
sujet
je vous suggère de regarder précisément
lors du prochain PLFSS je parle pas du
pvsse là du prochain pdfc 2024 il a
déclaré que les revenir sur un T2A la
tarification d'activité ce qui régit
c'est quelque chose essentiel
parce que aujourd'hui moi j'ai présidé
pendant 12 ans un conseil de
surveillance de Chu un jour sans m'agacé
je dis
au directeur général qui vous rapporte
le plus à l'hôpital c'est une chimio
supplémentaire
donc aujourd'hui cette remise en cause
de la T2A si elle se fait à mon avis
elle sera pas en une année mais c'est un
outil
pour les projets d'établissement afin de
remettre au centre
la personne et je pense que le moment
est venu
à travers la covid qu'est-ce qu'on a
constaté on a constaté qu'on savait très
tôt
il y a eu peut-être ici ou là des
difficultés
on n'a pas mesuré
pour des personnes âgées ou des
étudiants toutes les conséquences de la
médecine de la personne ces conséquences
en santé mentales je pense que ce sujet
là doit être réellement en toile de fond
de nos réflexions qu'on aura et que vous
aurez éventuellement dans les mois qui
viennent il faut interpeller la
communauté médicale
la conférence des doyens elle est
peut-être pour ça pourquoi on n'aime pas
des pays pH ne sont pas de Dieu
même si ça se résume pas au PIPA ça
serait simple ça concerne les
aides-soignants et les soignants et
pourquoi pourquoi l'Inserm il y a pas à
part quelques à dire jaune
privilégié comme travail que fait Régis
pourquoi il y a pas des des unités
inserts pourquoi l'ANR ne fait pas
d'appel à projet mais je pense que c'est
sur ce terrain là qu'il faut aller parce
que
tout le monde dit soit par les chiffres
parfait mais concrètement aujourd'hui
même dans la localisation dans certains
hôpitaux les soins palliatifs sont à pas
donc voilà moi je pense qu'il y a un
véritable sujet sur lequel il faut faire
évoluer les uns et les autres
alors j'ai des demandes de parole
Thibault Bazin merci monsieur le
Président merci Madame et messieurs pour
la réflexion éthique à laquelle vous
nous invitez parmi les vulnérabilités
vous avez mentionné l'âge la maladie et
le handicap
quelle précautions spécifiques vous
semble nécessaire pour que le handicap
n'implique pas de manière croissante un
sentiment d'indignité alors que les
moyens budgétaires et humains de notre
pays semble de plus en plus limité cette
allocation des ressources allocation
prioritaire pour les soignants peut
poser d'autres questions éthiques
d'ailleurs d'autres avis du CCNE
mentionnées cette problématique de la
location des ressources
concernant la dimension de la
temporalité
quel danger voyez vous si le déploiement
des soins palliatifs la mise en oeuvre
pleine et entière
des lois actuels sur l'ensemble du
territoire
est une condition
parallèle
et non préalable
alors
excusez-moi monsieur prendre les
autres collègues soit de poser aussi des
questions et puis
Jérôme Guedj
ah voilà c'est tout simple
bon tout ça tout ça et tout ça est
passionnant donc j'ai un peu comme
Caroline moi j'avais deux types de
questions la question au CO rédacteur de
cette loi de la nation
sur les les dispositions
dont il aurait aimé qu'elle figure mais
bon les choses ont été évoquées et puis
les deux corps rapporteurs de la vie sur
deux sur deux sujets spécifiques que
vous que vous mentionnez dans dans la
vie et qu'on n'a pas encore évoqué
j'avais prévu de vous parler des des
soins palliatifs mais évidemment enfin
c'est un petit peu le serpent qui se
mord la queue on dit pas une loi sèche
une malédiction j'ai pas d'ailleurs si
c'est une malédiction en tous les cas
une affirmation
récurrente de la nécessité de développer
les soins palliatifs
et en même temps le sentiment que les
choses n'infusent pas quantitativement
parce qu'il reste encore des gros trous
dans la raquette mais en parler et
qualitativement parce que la définition
même en réalité de ce que sont ces soins
palliatifs ce qui derrière me ramène
plutôt à la question de la place de la
mort au sens large dans le système de
santé en fait c'est la vérité de la
question c'est-à-dire l'acceptation de
la de la possibilité de la mort sinon de
sa centralité dans le système de santé
et ça va d'ailleurs au-delà des seules
questions relatives à
aux soins aux soins palliatifs on peut
évoquer plein de choses qui d'ailleurs
pourrait trouver sa place le moment venu
pardon de faire des pas de côté mais on
est là pour évaluer la loi actuelle et
pas pour parler la loi future donc je
garde ça pour d'autres pour d'autres
enceintes mais je pense notamment à la
place de la mort physique au rite à
accompagnement etc enfin bon alors j'en
viens donc voilà et donc dans votre
questionnement sur cette c'est
difficulté vous nous dites c'est pas la
seule question des moyens qui a un enjeu
d'aculturation et là au regard des
recommandations que vous formulez moi
j'ai envie un petit peu de creuser c'est
à dire concrètement
que ce soit le le l'enseignement
universitaire ou la recherche en matière
de soins palliatifs
c'est où que ça pêche dans la montée en
puissance
dans leur prise en compte dans le
système de santé
est-ce que ça doit aller à en faire un
argument opposable à des choses qui vont
compter pour les acteurs dans la
certification des établissements de
santé dans la tarification on vient de
le mentionner mais c'est à un moment
donné ce que le seul bon vouloir
ne se heurte pas à une inertie un
problème de culture est qu'à un moment
donné il faut être un peu faut être un
peu péremptoire c'est la première
question et la deuxième je vais la faire
plus brève sur un sujet qui me tient à
coeur que sont les établissements
médico-sociaux dans dans la dans la vie
que vous avez vous avez soumis vous vous
pointez le développement insuffisant de
la sédation profonde dans les à la fois
à domicile et dans les ESMS
donc c'est un sujet alors qui
paradoxalement a été
comment dire exciper par la crise
sanitaire et avec le recours midazolam
pendant
les situations de détresse respiratoires
et l'accélération de la réglementation
pour permettre mais là ce qu'on a pas
encore plus
une problématique spécifique pour ce
lieu où
normalement 150000 personnes 17 chaque
année enfin un quart des résidents
d'EHPAD des 7 chaque année même s'il y
en a 20 ou 30 000 qui vont avoir une
dernière hospitalisation et des CD à
l'hôpital ce qui d'ailleurs pose aussi
de la question de savoir si dans cette
fin de vie là mieux vaudrait peut-être
décéder peut-être dans des meilleures
conditions dans un établissement
médico-social préparer à cela plutôt que
dans des conditions mauvaises dans un
établissement sanitaire voilà et donc là
ma question précise c'est qu'est-ce que
vous avez
identifié dans comme insuffisance
au-delà de celle des difficultés qui ont
été pour partir réglées sur les
capacités de prescription mais
d'ailleurs je sais même c'était que
temporaire pendant la crise sanitaire
c'était que temporaire donc il y a la
question y compris législatives et
réglementaire du jusqu'où et dans
quelles conditions le personnel soignant
dans les EHPAD peut aussi participer de
cette décision de sédation profonde pour
éviter d'ailleurs le recours à une
hospitalisation et rajouter du trauma
autrement voilà merci
merci et dernière intervention Laurent
Pagny fosse
pardon merci merci monsieur le président
madame messieurs alors deux questions
qui
dans le sens où prolongement des
questions qui ont été posées là la
première
concerne le défaut les carences dans
l'application de la loi actuelle du
droit actuel on a soulevé à plusieurs
reprises dans les différentes auditions
les différents groupes de travail
auxquels on peut participer il y a un
problème de formation au niveau des
professionnels il y a un problème bien
sûr de moyen et il y a aussi un problème
je crois d'information auprès du grand
public
ces problèmes là
cumulés font qu'aujourd'hui
la culture la pratique du soin palliatif
au sens très large fait défaut dans
notre pays et de manière différenciée
selon les territoires en fait on est à
priori assez conscient sur le fait que
il y a un problème de moyens mais il
semblerait qu'il n'y ait pas que ça et
ma première question c'est pour pour
vous qui avez réflexe qui réfléchi
depuis très longtemps d'un point de vue
législatif c'est un produit purement
professionnel éthique y a-t-il des
choses qui peuvent être mises en oeuvre
assez rapidement
qui ne relève pas forcément de moyens
qui eux prendront forcément du temps
voilà c'est une question assez assez
précise et qui fait appel à votre
expérience en fait ma deuxième question
c'est c'est la relation et la
perturbation mais vous l'avez déjà un
peu évoqué donc j'ai un peu votre
réponse c'est entre le droit actuel
notre loi avec la sédation profonde
continue
et ce à quoi nous réfléchissons ça a été
dit on ne doit pas le dire mais on y
pense quand même malgré tout
l'éventuelle réalisation de nouveaux
droits et
de quelle manière la non-implication
correcte de la loi actuelle vient
perturber cette réflexion et alors je
réfléchissais de la manière opposée un
peu à la vôtre mais c'est
pour prolonger un petit peu cette
réflexion c'est que j'avais le sentiment
que
que l'on applique ou pas pleinement la
loi actuelle la réflexion sur un trois
nouveau est une réflexion différente
bien sûr ce sont des choses très proches
pour autant c'est un droit nouveau qui
n'enlève rien à la loi qui a été votée
en 2006 au premier guerre 2006 et
qui concernerait finalement peu de gens
et mais qui répondrait à cette demande
voir cette volonté vous l'avez précisé
qui reste très exceptionnel qui est
l'aide d'activor mourir l'assistance au
suicide mais voilà et je vois bien au
fil des entretiens que il y a une
perturbation qui est très forte entre
ces deux sujets évidemment si proche
mais pourtant je crois différents je
voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus je
vous remercie
Annabelle mais pour
répondre à la première question
qui rejoint d'ailleurs un peu votre
question faut-il qu'une
politique
de développement des soins palliatifs
étaient non seulement mise en œuvre mais
est abouti pour qu'on ouvre le débat sur
je suis assez d'accord avec votre
analyse sur une question liée mais
différente que la question de l'aide
active puisqu'elle ne s'adresse pas à
tout à fait au même au même situation
c'est un point de discussion qui a eu et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
publié cet avis différents où cette
réserve
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'il
faut un engagement
clair net fort qui ne se limite pas la
question des soins palliatifs c'est pour
ça que j'ai utilisé le terme de
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
parce que ça m'apparaît ça m'apparaît
être une question enfin réduire cette
réflexion à la question de la fin de vie
ne me semble pas me semble assez
limitatif je pense qu'il faut absolument
qu'on
ait une vraie un vrai engagement un
choix politique peut-être je sais pas
comment les choses peuvent se faire mais
en tout cas il faut que les choses
soient claires sans qu'on se retrouve
pour vous parler des établissements
médico-sociaux
pour moi et de là où je me situe comme
médecin
dans le champ hospital universitaire etc
je considère que le haut lieu de
l'accompagnement et des soins palliatifs
c'est dans les établissements médicaux
sociaux ça devrait être non établissons
médicaux sociaux il y a une telle
densité de questions éthique il y a une
telle densité de questions qui est liée
à la question de la finitude et de la
mort dès qu'on entre dans un état on
sait bien que ce n'est pas pour débuter
une vie mais peut-être débuter une fin
de vie
et de faire alors ça n'est pas qu'une
question de moyens c'est aussi une
question effectivement
de formation
etc mais c'est aussi une question de
mobilisation des moyens existants
personnellement je crois beaucoup
aux collaboration qui existent sur des
logiques de territoire entre les équipes
mobiles de soins souvent rattachés à un
établissement de santé mais peut-être
que la une des priorités et d'aller là
où il y a le plus de besoin et la
question des besoins elle se pose pas à
ce moment-là pour les sympathiques mais
pour l'accompagnement du vieillissement
il reste de mon point de vue et elle se
pose il reste à mon avis impossible de
faire de l'accompagnement bien mené
quand on n'a pas le personnel suffisant
quand dans un EHPAD on manque de
personnel et où le
la nuit il y a par exemple une
infirmière pour une trentaine de
résidences je ne vois pas comment on
peut
une équipe de soins elle n'est pas c'est
un lieu de soins palliatif pour les
raisons d'accompagnement enfin
pardon
dans l'absolu vous avez raison mais dans
la réalité puisqu'il y a aussi un
principe de réalité qui fait que
je pense réellement qu'un EHPAD qui
serait renforcé
alors qu'on aurait pensé des
alternatives aussi à l'épannes
qui travailleraient ça m'apparait
fondamental aussi dans la même mais
c'est un autre sujet
[Musique]
développer des compétences
universitaires j'ai porté d'ailleurs
lorsque je dirige un plan de sympathique
l'idée de nommer des professeurs qui ne
soient pas forcément des médecins autour
de ces questions là
comme universitaire
puisqu'on parle d'interdisciplinarité et
bien la compétence universitaire elle
peut venir ailleurs et l'urgence qu'il y
aurait aujourd'hui c'est de prendre le
temps de considérer que si on développe
des gens pour former à culture et
et comprendre qu'on se donne les moyens
d'avoir la possibilité de mener des
travaux de recherche
spécial avec des appels approches
spécifiques effectivement dans 10 ans
dans 15 ans on pourra évaluer
un impact tout cela aujourd'hui à mon
avis c'est aussi pour ça que si on
considère
qu'il faut attendre les résultats d'une
politique qui nécessiterait un
engagement clair explicite puis les
moyens Haddock tout en étant respectueux
des limites de ces moyens je crois que
ça va être stupide
il me semble que
on laisserait sur le côté des situations
de souffrance existentielle dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure qui ne relève pas
forcément de la toute fin de vie et qui
pourtant à mon avis interroge la
question d'une évolution éventuelle du
droit de mon point de vue c'est
important de notre point de vue
le neutre étant la majorité des membres
du CCNE mais pas tous les membres du
CCNE il nous a par important de traiter
ces deux c'est de dimensions en
parallèle mais ne pas engager une
véritable politique d'accompagnement du
personnel en situation de vulnérabilité
rendrait caduque l'intérêt voire
dangereux l'intérêt d'ouvrir la porte de
l'aide activa mourir c'est comme ça
qu'on voit les choses alors dans
l'immédiat quand même
je pense qu'il n'est pas impossible de
travailler au renforcement qui est
beaucoup moins coûteux que celui des
unités de son relatif au renforcement
des équipes mobiles de soins palliatifs
pour qu'elles aient une implantation
territoriale il n'est pas normal que
dans un territoire il n'y ait pas de
possibilité d'accès pour ne pas pour une
maison d'accueil spécialisée pour un
foyer d'accueil médicalisé à des
compétences et vous savez que la
fonction des équipes dites mobile c'est
le transfert de compétences c'est pas se
substituer c'est aider les personnes à
et de mon point de vue c'est quelque
chose qui à coup limité pourrait
permettre un développement tout de même
plus rapide
sur la question la temporalité
en réponse à la question de poser
monsieur Bazin sur pourquoi qu'elle
risque de développer en parallèle soit
un palliatif et puis ouverture d'une loi
qui revient aussi à la question que vous
posiez pour être tout à fait honnête
moi j'ai pas du tout eu la position que
je tiens devant vous maintenant je
l'avais pas je l'ai pas eu depuis le
début c'est à dire que pendant toute la
moitié de notre des travaux de la
commission du CCNE j'étais assez
persuadé qu'effectivement il y a des cas
pour lesquels la question de faire
évoluer la loi se pose que c'est qu'à
son peu nombreux et qu'il faut sans
doute la faire évoluer la raison qui m'a
fait alors je parle en mon nom on est 8
chacun avec on parle de voilà de
d'horizon différents et mais moi ce qui
m'a fait tout à fait changer de
perception c'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer depuis une heure
et demie c'est à dire que
finalement
ça n'est pas possible que je crois de
tenir les deux parce que le débat sur
l'ouverture de la loi confisque tout et
vous voyez bien qu'on a parlé alors que
ici il s'agit d'une commission
d'évaluation de la loi que les Leonetti
on a parlé je pense
aux trois quarts d'une évolution
possible de la loi vers l'aide active à
mourir et un quart des soins palliatifs
j'exagère peut-être un peu mais à peine
et en fait c'est ce qui se passe et
c'est ce qui s'est passé notre notre
avis du CCNE porte très très largement
sur justement la question de
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie et il
a été reçu dans les médias presque
uniquement pour la partie des
recommandations vers qu'est-ce que
serait un éthique pour pour une
évolution de la loi donc voilà premier
argument c'est l'argument de la
réception en fait qui en effet c'est que
si on envisage les deux en même temps et
bien le grand public
les médias etc pensent enfin voilà vous
l'évolution de cette évolution pour
quelques cas particulier en fait
confisque le débat l'eau du coup
l'autre question qui se pose derrière
c'est on dispose on sait très bien qu'on
manque de ressources dans notre système
de santé et voilà on manque de
ressources sociales et politiques
faire avancer vraiment l'accompagnement
de la fin de vie pour tout le monde et
donc faire
de façon très très majeure progresser le
soin palliatifs ça va prendre énormément
de temps d'argent de volonté etc
on sait très bien que ça va prendre du
temps donc notre notre inquiétude pour
répondre à la question quelle est
l'inquiétude si on fait ça en parallèle
si on fait ça en parallèle ce qui va se
passer c'est que ça sera plus facile de
laisser les personnes
choisir et toute là et toute la question
du choix choisir de mourir vite parce
que et donc la question que nous posons
c'est quel est ce choix quelle est la
liberté derrière ce choix pour que il y
ait autonomie et liberté il faut qu'il y
ait les différents termes du choix qui
soit possible et s'il y a un terme qui
est beaucoup plus possible que l'autre
voir que l'autre terme n'est pas
possible du tout ça n'est plus un choix
donc nous en fait voilà nous
questionnons la question de l'autonomie
et de la vraie liberté
oui Alain classe
oui je crois que la belle a raison faut
revenir à la vie du CCN
moi je suis pas des comptes de
il n'y a pas d'autonomie sans solidarité
et je vais dire c'est le rôle central
des soins palliatifs
on a dit assez précisément s'il était
souhaitable il est trop facile pour le
coup de
s'adresser
aux politiques en disant il manque de
l'argent assurément il manque peut-être
de l'argent mais comme l'a dit
Régis
une encra toujours
pas dire ici bon
c'est vraiment
un élément essentiel de notre projet de
société
moi je pense que le modèle médical
aujourd'hui
par rapport aux évolutions
technologiques il y a et qui va être à
mon avis un sujet central pour le CNE
dans les dans les années qui viennent
vous remettent au cœur la politique une
politique médicale pour la personne
c'est essentiel mais on fera pas quelque
soit les gouvernements ils ne font pas
seuls quel que soit les parlementaires
moi je connais le fonctionnement de
l'université et dans cette grande
supérieure
sont les Pères
s'il y a pas cette prise de conscience
de la communauté médicale on avancera
pas
est-ce que il y a que le curatif qui a
la primeur
la primeur des concours la primeur des
postes etc c'est ça
introduire les sciences humaines on sait
très bien pour entrer dans les détails
mais une publication aujourd'hui
scientifique
où on introduit les sciences humaines
je peux vous dire qu'elle est pas cotée
en haut
donc ça c'est moi je pense le rôle
dans notre réflexion collective vous en
tant que parlementaire nous en tant que
comité nationality d'insister là-dessus
et je pense
que le politique au sens noble du terme
à des leviers à des leviers pour faire
évoluer les esprits
parce que nous racontons pas d'histoire
encore
certains services on est très critique
sur la taxi favori on veut pas entendre
parler
mais parfois pour pousser
c'est ça la réalité parfois les types ne
sont pas acceptés naturellement dans un
processus d'accompagnement de la
personne donc il faut qu'on je pense que
c'est centrales ça mais nous posons pas
de peut-être de différence qu'on a avec
les collègues du CC2 qui ont signé
je pense qu'on ne doit pas se dire entre
nous
que ça serait la solution de facilité
passionnerai pas régler des points
politiques ça je peux pas l'excepter
on vous dit quelqu'un de libre je ne
peux pas l'accepter
l'aide active à mourir
elle se pose
depuis un certain nombre d'années et
c'est pas évident et notre société est
très fracturée sur ce sujet là malgré
les sondages mais à partir du moment
où législateur
a voté un jour
qu'un patient après discussion peut
demander l'arrêt de ces traitements
ne soyons pas
mettons pas la tête dans le sable ça
veut dire que le pronostic vital est
engagé
c'était assumé ça donc il faut il faut
réfléchir à toutes les décisions qui ont
été prises c'est pas c'est pas des
accumulations de décision il y a une
logique depuis 20 ans quel que soit il y
a une logique qui s'est passé alors
le seul sujet auquel moi je suis je
prête attention c'est dire c'est
si législateur décidait c'est une porte
ouverte on n'aura pas des limites
c'est ça le risque et des questions
autour du handicap autour de vrais
sujets
nous on a essayé très franchement sur ce
sujet d'aborder jusqu'au bout la notion
de solidarité et d'autonomie et je
reviens au débat qui avait entre le
président tout à l'heure et Régis Aubry
la demande n'est pas l'acceptation
et pour qu'une autonomie puisse se
manifester de façon libre et éclairée il
faut qu'il y ait une solidarité dans la
collégialité pour faire émerger cette
décision je crois que c'est essentiel
voilà ce qu'on a beau dire alors sur les
EHPAD
j'entendais ce que vous disiez
le chantier
c'est comment concilier dans ces
structures collectives
un EHPAD qui soit à la fois un lieu de
vie
et un lieu plus médicalisé c'est ça
qu'il s'agit
quand vous avez qu'un médecin
coordonnateur et une infirmière
coordonnatrice le vendredi soir à 18h si
un pépin c'est les urgences
mais comment ce lieu qu'on doit plus
médicalisé moi je rejoins ce que dit
Régis c'est la priorité peut-être
qu'elle soit palliatifs là comment ça
demeure aussi un lieu de vie
et c'est une question de peut-être de
gros sous mais c'est une question aussi
de modèles qu'on veut avoir et je pense
que le débat maintient à domicile ou est
pas ça tient ça tient pas la route les
deux peuvent se justifier dans des
situations bien différentes etc
mais pour en revenir au CCE on n'a pas
on a fait le constat sur la loi de 2016
je crois que il est clair
[Musique]
ce qui prouve bien que le Parlement doit
évaluer ses lois il doit les faire mais
doit les évaluer
mais
l'aide active à mourir est très lié au
sujet de soins palliatifs la question
qui va demeurer pour vous
est-ce que c'est un simple sujet de
société
que la société doit prendre en compte ou
c'est un sujet qui implique
qui implique des médecins
j'entends aujourd'hui en disant
on peut accepter cette demande sociétale
mais ça nous concerne pas
faudra répondre à ça
et je pense on en discutait avec Régis
en venant
je pense qu'on en France si le
législateur décidait dans cette
direction
qu'une solution associative de
correspond pas à notre modèle de pensée
solution anglo-saxonne
correspond pas à dire confié à une
association
[Musique]
je crois que c'est le sujet majeur
merci infiniment à vous trois Madame et
Monsieur de d'avoir bien voulu répondre
à nos questionnements je renouvelle les
excuses du corps rapporteur bloqué par
un train mais qui ne manquera pas de de
prendre connaissance du compte rendu
voilà je vous remercie beaucoup